[Música]
este paciente siempre recupera
y luego otra vez recae
y me imaginé también por falta como dice
un buen
alimentación porque es un tratamiento
muy fuerte
[Música]
aquí nosotros estamos dijo
esperando nuevos seis meses siete meses
siete meses esperando la comida y
de dónde vamos
esperando comida no no no tenemos que
estar esperando que nosotros tenemos que
talar para uno come
[Música]
hay personas que lo portan y no quieren
aceptar esa realidad y se entrega para
morir o sea me pasan casos de personas
por la mente que están en esa situación
[Música]
para hoy en mano todo algo más
el nombre actual
[Música]
28 calle mur
mayer
[Música]
que quiera
yo canal
[Música]